hey guys Pete here twin peak season 3 is
debuting in four days I suppose once you
see this so I have to tell you that
you're running out of time if you wanted
to rewatch the entire series plus the
movie and the missing pieces no need to
panic though I'm going to go through
which characters we know who are
returning kind of where they were at at
the end of the story as a refresher for
you guys and then the ones that we know
are not returning for sure one thing to
keep in mind here is that the Twin Peaks
production has been super silent about
everything David Lynch has wanted it to
be a mystery that's his whole deal
basically and so that it has been pretty
tight-lipped as you know there haven't
been many trailers but we have finally
got a little bit of themes from the new
season so you could see that playing in
the background now so let's start with
the main character Tom McLaughlin played
Special Agent Dale Cooper obviously he's
coming back I mean there really couldn't
be a show without him as far as I'm
concerned so what was he doing at the
end of the original run of Twin Peaks
well if you don't remember I'm surprised
that you watched it at all because it
was one of the biggest cliffhangers and
it's been hanging for about 27 years but
if you're just getting back into a Twin
Peaks frame of mind Dale Cooper went
into what we presume to be the Black
Lodge or at least a waiting room and we
saw the very last scene of season 2 was
him staring into the mirror and we
recognized that he is possessed by the
spirit Bob so it's pretty widely
accepted that now there are two Dale's
the good Dale who's in the lodge as any
told Laura and the possessed or whatever
you would call it the Bob Cooper who is
back in Twin Peaks at least that's where
he was 27 years ago
speaking of Annie this was also a
cliffhanger and we all kind of assumed
that we'd find out what was going on
with her but according to all the news
Heather Graham has not been recast and
has said she wanted to be in it but just
isn't so presumably that means that
Annie is gone we don't know why I have
no idea there's really no good theory
that I have read
about that so unless they are really
playing with us which I don't think
there is I'm not going to get into
spoilers here but even through all the
secrecy there was a lot of different
stuff from the sets that got out so
since there's nothing with Heather
Graham or anything about Annie I'm going
to presume that she is not involved in
season 3 another big character if you
might remember it was Laura Palmer she
was the homecoming queen who was killed
Pete Martell found her in the very
beginning of the pilot Laura is coming
back when we last saw her she was in the
lodge talking to Dale and remember there
was that ominous I'll see you in 25
years and if you're wondering what's
going on with that well you join the
club except for just keep in mind that
in fire walk with me bob was trying to
possess Laura that was his intention but
she's she's getting killed she puts on
the ring and that seems to have
protected her from being possessed but
it also seems to have put her in the
lodge so I don't imagine we'll see her
outside of the lodge but who knows now
Cheryl Lee who played Laura Palmer also
played Maddie Ferguson and so she's back
and we don't know which role I mean I
guess it's we don't know if she'll be
playing both roles or just Laura
I mean Laura is definitely going to be
involved but we don't know about Maddie
Laura's father played by actor ray wise
Leland Palmer is also set to come back
if you remember he died but we did see
him inside the lodge and there's some
speculation that he may be the new face
of Bob but we really don't know that's
just speculation so Leland will either
be flashbacks or in the lodge or he will
be the current day version of Bob
because the actor who played Bob Frank
Silva died in 1995 Leland's wife Sarah
has shown up in several of the new
images from season 3 so we know she'll
be back there's not much that we can
figure out from what we've seen she
seems to be shopping for liquor in the
liquor store but beyond that we're not
sure what her role will be another big
character are Audrey Horne who was not
available when they shot fire walk with
me we'll be returning
in season three sherilyn fenn has worked
quite a bit since then so we've seen her
recently I think the last thing I saw
her in was Ray Donovan now if you don't
remember the last time we saw Audrey she
had handcuffed herself to the bulks just
before the bomb went off
killing Andrew Packard in the time since
the last episode we saw her in we found
out from the secret history of Twin
Peaks that Mark Ross put out that she
actually did survive the blast but only
because Pete Martel blocked her from the
direct explosion now we don't know what
her status is we know that she was
injured very severely there's talk about
her father Benjamin sitting by her side
so we don't really know what kind of
shape she'll be in 25 years later but
she is going to be a you know figure
heavily in the story going forward I
mentioned her father Benjamin Horne you
remember he sort of had an emotional or
psychological roller coaster ride
through season 2 which wasn't my
favorite part of the story but we did
find out that he will be coming back in
the show we knew he had kind of like
tried to turn to the good side or
whatever you would call it and we know
that he was supposedly by audrey side
and that was the last thing we heard of
him doing his brother Jerry will also be
back but Audrey's brother you know the
guy who was wearing the headdress and
you know a patient of dr. Jacoby he will
not be returning as far as we know one
of the biggest disappointments is that
sheriff Perry has Truman will not be
returning the actor Michael on keen
basically said that he had retired after
his last work and he was not interested
in doing Twin Peaks now there is a
replacement for him Robert Forester will
be penc playing his brother at least
that's what I've read the last is that
he's Frank Truman harry s truman 's
brother there was some confusion of
whether he would just play harry but
yeah they're they're making him a new
character but he's from the same family
as far as I know so we won't have that
normal back and forth that we had
between harry s truman and cooper as far
as the other deputies go we've seen
walk in some of the released material
he'll be back and so will Andy if you
don't remember Andy was with Lucy Moran
there was a store a sub story in season
2 where she was trying to decide between
him and dick Tremaine as to who would be
the father of her baby
and she ultimately picked Andy Lucy
Moran is coming back we've seen photos
of the actor Kimmie Robertson showing up
in the new trailers and yes oh she
should have a child now that should be
around 25 years old and her and Andy
should still be together as far as we
know besides the fact that Annie isn't
returning another pivotal character that
we know isn't coming back is Donna
Hayward now this isn't a huge surprise
since Donna was recast in fire walk with
me Laura Flynn Boyle played Donna in the
TV series but more Kelly played Donna in
the movie it's a lot of speculation as
to why Donna was recast it pretty much
goes back and forth between whether oil
was you know too busy or perhaps you
know that there was problems you know
qualms about some nude scenes that more
Kelly eventually did but either way we
know for sure that neither actress has
been cast for season 3 Donna's father on
the other hand will be returning doctor
will Hayward who's played by Warren
Frost who is mark frost father was able
to shoot all of his scenes before his
unfortunate passing earlier this year so
even though we know that Warner Frost
has passed away he will be involved in
season 3 his wife on the other hand is
not listed at least the actress who
played her in the TV series so we're not
really sure what role dr. will will play
or where the rest of his family is James
who pretty much dated everybody in the
story he's played by James Marshall is
coming back when we last saw James he
had taken off after his romance with the
older woman and he was headed towards
the coast I believe and you know he's
off to see the world so we're not really
sure what he'll be doing when he
stack Shelly Johnson who was played by
machen a Mick witch that's I'm sure I
just murdered that name she was the wife
of Leo Johnson and she worked as a
waitress at the Double R she will be
returning you remember when we last saw
her she was paired up with Bobby Bobby
Briggs who will also be returning the
actress who plays Shelley has been
active on social media she's also in
that show
Riverdale so she has been posting quite
a bit of stuff about Twin Peaks and the
revival and being excited about it so
we're assuming she'll have a major role
her deranged drug-dealing husband Leo
who turned invalid remember when we last
saw him he was trapped in Windom Earles
cabin he is not listed to return the
actor who played Leo isn't on any of the
lists and we haven't heard any news of
his return so he probably met his end in
that cabin Shelley's new boyfriend Bobby
Briggs is coming back though when we
last saw Bobby he was trying to get in
with Benjamin Horne he sort of hung
around through the civil war phase of
Benjamin Horne psychosis and we're not
really sure where he ended up but he
could be a major player in the new
season Bobby's father Major garland
Briggs who was one of my favorite
characters will not be returning
unfortunately the actor who played him
Donna Davis suffered a heart attack in
2008 and passed away so he will not be
involved not as the same person and I
would imagine that someone will be
replacing his role because if you really
dig into what was going on with him you
remember he always said that it was
classified but he was there I feel like
a lot of the stuff revolving around his
character will figure into season 3 as
it did in the secret history so not sure
how we'll be introduced to his successor
I guess would be the right word but I
think he will have some sort of a
successor that will take up that role
they get Hurley and his wife Nadine are
both returning we've seen them in new
photos and we have to imagine that be
doing about the same thing that they
were you remembered Nadine sort of went
through a phase where she thought she
was a team
ager and had superhuman strength but she
went back to her normal self by the end
of season 2 also Norma Jennings Ed's
side romance will be returning remember
she was the manager of the Double R she
could still be that or maybe Shelley has
taken her place and she'll just be
something else but we know that the
actress who plays her Peggy Lipton is
going to be in the show
Norma's husband Hank who was played by
Chris Mulkey will not be returning in
the secret history we found out that he
was killed in jail by a cousin of the
Renault z-- dr. Lawrence Jacobi just
showed up in a brand new photo this
morning my time and so he will be
returning when we last saw him he was
sort of bringing Sarah Palmer to deliver
a message to major Briggs so he's
definitely back we don't know what he'll
be up to by this time another actor who
has passed away recently Miguel Ferrer
played agent Albert Rosenfeld will be
returning he was completed with filming
his scene so he will be there even
though he has since passed last time we
saw Albert he was headed to arrest Josie
Packard but of course she died whenever
he got there
Denis Bryson who used to be Dennis
Bryson and played by David Duchovny is
listed as a returning actor the last
time we saw the agent
she was rescuing Cooper from John
Renault some people have reported seeing
Duchovny on the set in his female attire
so we're expecting that Denis is still
very much Denyce to round things out
Mike or the spirit mic that inhabits
Philip Michael Gerard the shoe salesman
is returning last we saw Mike he helped
to provide some crucial clues that help
solve Laura's murder and we learned a
little bit more about him in fire walk
with me the arm or the man from another
place who is the embodiment of Mike's
chopped off arm and really an icon for
the series the actor Michael J Anderson
is not listed to return he initially was
supposed to be involved but it looks
like that he
a falling out with David Lynch and was
difficult to work with and is honestly
been trolling the series on the internet
ever since I'm not really sure I don't
want to speculate on what's going on
with the actor but he will not be
involved with season 3 his counterpart
the giant is supposed to be involved and
that's a good thing and if you remember
he said when next time you see him he
will not be the same so they haven't out
there they can just replace him with a
different actor and his role can change
Margaret Lanterman the log Lady another
one of my favorite characters has also
passed away since season two wrapped up
but she is listed as an actress in the
new season and she may have shot some
scenes before her passing the log lady
brings up some interesting thinking - if
if she hasn't shot in any scenes but
still is listed there is possibilities
that this new series will pull from old
footage like if you've never seen it
there were actually introductions for
all the episodes with the log Lady and
things like that so there could be extra
footage that we still haven't seen
floating around that they could use the
last actor is also a director and David
Lynch is who I'm talking about and he
played the role of agent Gordon Cole he
was Coop's boss essentially and we do
know for a fact that he will be
returning so this video has gotten quite
long I don't want to delve into too much
speculation that is the major characters
that we know are returning there are a
ton of new characters though actually
quite a few more than there are
returning characters in the background
here is the most recent list I've seen
of returning characters a couple that I
missed on mention real quickly we have
run at Pulaski supposed to be back Heidi
who works at the double ARA who's also
supposed to be in the show Sylvia Horne
Ben Horne's wife who didn't play a large
role but will be back the Roadhouse
singer and my favorite that I can't
believe I didn't mention earlier call
rod he's played by Terry
Stanton he might remember him from fire
walk with me he was the manager of the
fat trout trailer park which is where
Teresa banks lived in the secret history
it appears that the fat trout trailer
parks has actually been moved to Twin
Peaks so we make it the back end story
of that another character who's not on
this list that's supposed to be coming
back is the jumping man and some
characters that I didn't mention who
aren't returning Josie is not supposed
to be involved and that's kind of a
bummer considering that she had that
weird death team where we saw her face
in the wood that looked like it was
going to lead somewhere but perhaps it
will not also the Tremont family the
grandmother and her grandson there's no
mention of those actors and I mentioned
that the secret history told us that
Pete had saved audrey Pete Martell so he
is no longer involved the actor who
played him Jack Nance has passed away as
is and also his wife Katherine Motel
does not seem to be involved so that
whole ghostwood storyline may just have
evaporated one way or the other but yeah
Piper Laurie who played Catherine
Martell is also not listed to be
involved let me know who you're most
excited about seeing return what you
think all these characters have been up
to and let's have a conversation in the
days leading up to the season 3 debut
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon